Spider-Man: No Way Home is one of the MCU's
biggest successes, both in terms of critical
response and box office numbers.
While the world is still reeling from the
movie's shock cameos, there were plenty of
monumental moments in the film that didn't
include you-know-who.
Of course, Aunt May's death is easily No Way
Home's most devastating moment, but the ending
wasn't an easy pill to swallow, either.
After Doctor Strange performs the spell that
makes the world forget Peter Parker, MJ and
Ned's memories are wiped, and Peter chooses
not to tell them about their past together.
At the end of the movie, fans are left wondering
if MJ and Ned will ever remember who Peter
really is.
Of course, many people will be holding out
hope that MJ and Ned are going to remember
Peter as they once did, and if that's the
case, it's bound to occur in a future Spider-Man
movie.
But how could it actually happen?
Well, Sony producer Amy Pascal recently confirmed
to Fandango that the studios are getting ready
to make the next Spider-Man film.
She also noted that Sony and Marvel are looking
at doing three more films, so Peter Parker
will have plenty of time to revert MJ and
Ned to their old selves.
Obviously, any ideas about how this will go
down are bound to be purely speculative in
nature.
Luckily, there are probably an infinite amount
of ways in which MJ and Ned might remember
Peter, especially now that the multiverse
has been fully unleashed.
The simplest way, however, would be to have
Doctor Strange perform another spell.
Naturally, Strange would need some convincing
since Stephen also doesn't remember Peter.
But you could argue that it wouldn't be too
hard for Peter to convince him that they have
a history if the youngster just explains some
of the events that occurred on Titan during
Avengers: Infinity War.
Only the heroes who were there on Titan could
possibly know what happened, and Strange would
quickly accept the possibility his memory
has been tampered with.
"I'm Peter, by the way."
"Doctor Strange."
"Oh, we're using our made-up names.
I'm Spider-Man, then."
After all, No Way Home makes clear that he
has performed the spell before, so it's not
like the mind-erasing trick would seem unusual
to him.
As simple as this idea is, that's the problem
— it's a little too simple.
If Ned and MJ's memories are to be restored,
it'll likely be in a more dramatic fashion
than simply asking Strange to make things
right.
With so many projects in the works in the
MCU and dozens of characters spread throughout
them, it's not a far-fetched idea to think
someone else outside of the Spider-Man films
can help with Ned and MJ's amnesia.
Wanda Maximoff is now more powerful than ever
as the Scarlet Witch, and we know she's dabbled
in mind control on occasion.
Wanda is a trickier player than Strange, however,
and you wouldn't want her putting illusions
into Ned and MJ's heads.
Still, maybe there's a more sensitive tweak
to her powers via which she can undo Strange's
spell.
In this case, though, there would have to
be some reason for Peter and Wanda to meet
up.
While Elizabeth Olsen is set to appear in
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness,
it seems unlikely that Holland will make a
cameo — and who knows what the MCU has in
store for Wanda after that movie is released?
One character who is rumored to show up in
the second Doctor Strange flick is Charles
Xavier.
Professor X knows a thing or two about mind
control, and if he effectively becomes canon
in the MCU, he might be someone whose powers
are available to Peter.
With all the mind powers in his arsenal, it's
almost a guarantee that Professor X could
retrieve erased memories from a subject, especially
when they live on in someone else.
That, of course, is assuming that Xavier even
makes it out of Multiverse of Madness.
There are plenty of other characters who could
also help in the quest to revert the memories
of Peter's friends, some of whom we haven't
even met yet.
Whoever it might be who lights the spark,
here's hoping it happens soon — because
what is the MCU Spider-Man without his Ned
and MJ?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.